I actually had other plans for the daily
cancellation today uh better plans you
might even say but then I saw this clip
of Nikki Haley all over Twitter and yes
I will keep calling a Twitter until the
day I die just like the football team in
Washington will always be the Redskins
the clip is from an interview Haley
recently did with NBC News where she was
asked about some of her recent comments
about race which the media has construed
as racist and this really shows you
already how meaningless the racism
charge is from the media like if they
can even make Nikki Haley into a far
right nazi racist then they can do it to
anyone and in this case the NBC
reporters were very concerned that Haley
had in recent days tried to earn an AC
quiddle on the racism charges by
pointing out that she has black friends
and NBC informs her informs her that
using the I have black friends excuse is
a Trope which is itself racist now I've
said before that the only problem with
using the I have black friends uh excuse
as a defense against racism is that you
are defending yourself against a racism
accusation in the first place to defend
yourself in the first place is to
already lose the minute you gravel to
these people and try to prove your
anti-racism credentials they own you
that's why the only appropriate response
when someone on the left calls you
racist is to look them in the eyes and
say I don't care that you think that of
me you aren't agreeing that you're
racist because you aren't but you also
aren't collapsing on the ground and
begging for their pardon and forgiveness
instead you're letting them know that
they their opinion of you and the labels
they put on you mean nothing to you and
they have no power over you now all that
said even if you shouldn't be allowing
yourself to be put on the defense in the
first place it's also the case that
objectively speaking I have black
friends is a great defense against a
racism accusation somebody who has black
a black friends is almost certainly not
racist against black people in fact
friendship with another human being
entails by definition that you do not
think that they are inferior to you
based on race or any other Factor
outside of their control because if you
do think that then they're not your
friend so if someone has black friends
they aren't racist against black people
like they that's pretty good indication
the idea the idea that this is somehow
an illegitimate defense or somehow
irrelevant to the racism question
entirely is totally absurd which is
something that Nikki Haley could have
pointed out in this exchange but instead
she went this
route we were the only Indian family in
our small southern town I was teased
every day for being
Brown so anyone that wants to question
it can go back and look at what I've
said on how hard it was to grow up in
the Deep South as a brown girl anybody
can look at my record and see when
Walter Scott was shot down by a dirty
cop how I made sure that the Walter
Scott family didn't suffer because we
put the first body camera bill in the
country in place anybody can look at the
fact fact that when we had nine amazing
Souls D in mother Emanuel Church I did
something that no Republican or Democrat
ever wanted to touch which was call for
the Confederate flag to come down
because it would take two-thirds of the
House and Senate and was an impossible
feat I don't know what you're implying
with that but what I will tell you is
saying that I had black friends is a
source of Pride saying that I had white
friends is a source of Pride if you want
to know what it was like growing up I
was disqualified from a beauty pageant
because I wasn't white or black because
they didn't know where to put
me okay let's just uh slow down here and
take this one at a time first of all
just to address the elephant in the room
here Nikki Haley is not really brown or
at least if she is brown she's a very
light shade of it technically we're all
shades of brown from a color spectrum
perspective I've never seen a literal
white person like there are no people
with skin pigment the same shade as a
sheet of computer paper so if Nick
Haley's Brown she's only Brown in the
sense that any white person is brown I'm
not doubting that um Haley's family is
really from India they are but the point
is that if she doesn't tell you she's
brown you would never know in fact like
most people I didn't find out until this
election cycle that Haley is Indian and
when I found out like most people I said
what Nikki Haley isn't white and I had
to go check Wikipedia and sure enough
like oh she's from her family's from
India I had no idea all that to say her
stories of anti Brown persecution strain
credulity from the start and what are
the stories well she says that she was
disqualified from a beauty pageant for
being Brown we're supposed to believe
that way way back in the ancient times
of the 1980s South Carolina's beauty
pageant circuit had never encountered
anyone who hailed from Asia or anywhere
in the Middle East or anywhere in south
or Central America so they saw Nikki
slightly brownish skin and their minds
were blown they didn't know what to do
like they they looked at her and they
said wait a minute I've heard of black
people I've heard of white people but
what is this they make people in this
color I what do we do
here you know hit a button set off an
alarm it was a total panic it was
pandemonium this is what the beauty
pageant official apparently said to
Nikki sometime in the early 1980s um I
must confess that I find that somewhat
difficult to believe uh in fact it
sounds very similar to the to the single
woman who informs you that men aren't
interested in her because they are
intimidated by her staggering Beauty it
sounds like the most desperate cope of
all time I mean there are after all
other more obvious reasons why men may
not be interested in you just as there
are other more obvious reasons why you
might have been disqualified from a
beauty pageant but I guess we'll never
know I mean it is possible that beauty
pageant in South Carolina 40 years ago
had a policy that only people from
Africa Europe or North America were
allowed to participate it's possible
that black and white people were teaming
up
together to discriminate against Asians
um that's a team we don't see very of
like those are that's that's a that's
that's a you know an assortment a team
we don't see very often um and uh I
wasn't there I can't say for sure what I
can say for sure though is that there is
simply no way Nikki Haley was teased
every day for being Brown as she claims
I've never heard anyone being teased for
being Brown ever in my entire life um
I'm sure it's happened at various points
in American history but the claim that
she as someone who barely even qualifies
as brown was teased on a daily basis her
entire childhood because of her
brownness is just impossible to believe
if it was true I would say it's not the
worst thing in the world like every kid
is going to be teased for something and
if they choose your maybe very slightly
darker skin tone as the subject of
ridicule that's not too terrible All
Things Considered I mean it's better
than being called ugly or fat or a loser
or whatever every kid gets picked on by
someone for something it's an
unfortunate reality of growing up
especially in the school system uh and
none of it should be happening like no
one should be getting teased because
they have brown skin if that's even
happening I don't know I don't even know
what that would sound like but um of all
the things you could be teased for I'm
not sure why that would be any worse
than than any other other horrible
things that kids are said say to each
other um but that's assuming that this
really happened which it probably didn't
at least not at the rate and frequency
Nikki is claiming here but whether it
happened or not or however often it did
happen if it happened at all none of
that matters are you struggling with
back taxes do you have unfiled returns
this year the IRS is escalating
collections by adding 20,000 new agents
during these challenging times your best
offense is to use tax Network USA with
over 14 years of experience tax Network
USA has saved their clients over a
billion dollars in back taxes they
specialize in negotiating with the IRS
and aim to reduce your debt
significantly tax Network USA doesn't
just negotiate they protect your ass
assets from IRS seizures and manage your
yearly returns for ongoing compliance
importantly they are licensed to help
with all state tax issues regardless of
where you live in the US seize control
of your financial future now and don't
let tax issues overpower you contact tax
Network USA for immediate relief and
expert guidance call 1800 245 6000 or
visit TN
usa.com Walsh turn to tax Network USA
and find your path to financial peace of
mind that's TN usa.com Walsh first of
all
if you are a grown adult trying to gain
sympathy based on what your elementary
school peers said to you no matter what
they said to you no matter how rude they
were then you are pathetic it is just
not acceptable to be a 50-year-old adult
trying to earn pity points from what
some alleged schoolyard bully teased you
about 40 years ago and the only time
it's okay for an adult to bring up the
grade school bullying they suffered is
if they're talking to a child and trying
to encourage a child by saying you know
I went through it I turned out fine
you'll be okay like in that context
you'll be excused for drudging up those
memories but to bring it up to other
adults in an on camera interview no less
in a desperate attempt to make yourself
seem
sympathetic is just embarrassing on
every possible
level and it's all for nothing in the
end anyway because you cannot play the
victim game against the left and win
this is their game they own it they own
the stadium they run the league they're
paying the refs it's like trying to beat
the Kansas City Chiefs in the playoffs
the whole thing is rigged you can't win
you aren't allowed
to I'm the biggest victim so I'm right
is a move the left invented you can't
use it against
them why can't you use it against them
because because they could just say oh
that doesn't count when you do it what
do you mean it doesn't count when I well
we this is our this is our game we made
it up it's like have you ever tried to
play a
game with like a child that a child has
invented have you ever with my kids play
this game daddy we met what's the game
we made it up and then and I quickly
discovered that whatever we're doing in
this game all the rules are designed
just to make sure that somehow they win
and I don't win and this is exactly how
it works on the
left so you can't win and why would you
want to have some self-respect have some
dignity be a
grownup if they try to lead you into a
conversation like this just look at them
and
say you don't really think I'm racist
this is just a game you're playing but
even if you do think it I don't care I'm
not here to justify myself to you now
ask me about something that actually
matters or this conversation is
over that's all you have to say can you
imagine Nikki Hy had said
that like even I would have to I I would
do 15 minutes praising her just for that
alone it would be that
simple but Republicans like Nikki Haley
are just not capable belov it which is
why she is today once again and forever
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there